(Audience cheering and applauding)
Well, it's Thanksgiving week
and we're always thankful
when our first guest stops by.
That's why we're calling this whole hour,
'Gratitude with Garth.'
(Audience cheering and applauding)
He's the only artist in music history
to have nine albums to
be certified Diamond,
which means they each sold
over 10 million units.
Just in case you're wondering at home,
most artists have like one
album that might sell that much
and he's got nine.
His latest album is
called 'Time Traveler.'
It's available as part
of the limited series seven disc box set.
You can find it exclusively
at a Bass Pro shop near you
don't, man, if you go
there, you're gonna end up
with 50,000 things you
didn't know you want.
It's like Target, it's,
but it's a great store.
But you end up with everything
and you're like, I'm
totally gonna go fishing.
(audience laughing)
Everybody give it up for Garth Brooks.
(Audience cheering and applauding)
(band playing upbeat music)
- [Garth and Kelly] (indistinct chatter)
(Audience cheering and applauding)
- But happy Thanksgiving by the way.
- Thank you very much.
I'm gonna put gut hider on.
I love it.
(laughing)
- Thank you very much.
- (laughing) Woo, now I can gonna relax.
- Now it's, now it's out. That's it.
I love you right now.
(laughing)
Well wait. This is, all of this is we're,
it's like we're related,
but, so wait, what?
Today is all about gratitude,
which I think is perfect for you.
We were trying to find, 'cause
we love you on this show
we've had you on and we're, what can we do
that's like different and special?
And Thanksgiving was this week
and you are such a giving person,
but I think that you're
also always in a state
of like gratitude for everything
as well, which is cool.
'cause you recognize all the blessings.
- Yeah amen.
Well, you, you're that same way.
- I am but you're like the next degree.
We've talked about
this, me and my friends.
- Really ?
Yeah. They, everybody
thought I was like this
and then they, you were
introduced in their life
and they're like, oh no,
you don't even count.
But what does this, what does it mean
to like be grateful,
especially around Thanksgiving?
Like what do you do?
You go big for Thanksgiving, your family?
- Yeah, well, when
you're married to, well,
one of the greatest cooks on the planet.
- Oh my God.
Don't brag about it.
- Well, I won't, we'll talk about
how great of a singer she is.
- I know.
- And then we'll talk about that.
That's probably five and six on our list
of top 10 things to do.
But she, I think it's fun.
My thing is this and, and you
guys might feel the same way
when it comes to the future.
You know, I think it's what you're
just grateful for is just one more day.
Right, of getting to do this.
So I think that's it.
Just truthfully, if I could
say, what I'd love to say is
the day I take my last
breath on this planet,
I'd love for my three
girls to be around me.
And I love for the Queen to be around me,
but for as far as Miss
Yearwood, I don't know.
You know, I've said this before.
I found her in the past life.
I'll find her in the next.
She just, it's just I....
- Well have a great day everybody.
(Audience cheering and applauding)
- She makes it fun, you know?
She makes it really fun.
Don't cry at lunch, Garth.
Okay.
So it's amazing though.
It's such a beautiful love
between the two of you.
It is. And you are tearing up
and you're making me tear up
and my makeup artist is gonna kill me.
- I'm not tearing up.
- Yeah, you are.
Yeah, you are.
I love it.
So wait, so why time traveler?
Why the title of that?
- Well, you know, country music as well,
if not better than everybody.
And country music just stays sincere.
It does its thing, but
through the decades sometimes
it gets dressed up different.
And I swear you could
take two of these cuts
and you could play 'em in the
seventies. They would fit.
- I love it.
- You could take a couple of these cuts.
It'd be in the nineties. I
mean, that's kind of where,
you know, where our stuff was born.
And then the stuff that'll just go right
along with today's stuff.
So that's what I love about country music.
As much as you might dress it
different through the decades,
it still stays true to itself.
And so Time Traveler just seemed to pass
through all those eras of country music.
- Yeah, it's a cool title.
Well, in celebration of
Thanksgiving this week,
we are doing a little
'Gratitude with Garth' y'all
(upbeat music)
(Audience cheering)
Grateful for where you came from, right?
This is like something
that you always talk about, right?
- Amen.
- Yeah, me too.
- It's, it's, you're grateful
for where you're from
and you're grateful that you
kind of ended up where you're at.
If that makes any sense.
And people go, 'Hey, would you
change anything in the past?'
And you go, not if it
would change one thing
of where I'm at right now, right?
- Yeah, absolutely.
(Audience cheering)
- That's the thing.
- Yeah.
Even the bad stuff. Oh, even
the stuff that's not great
- Is the bad stuff bad?
I mean, here's the thing.
- Sometimes,
- So we talk about marriage sometimes
and sometimes marriage doesn't work out,
but the children you have,
they're the perfect mix
of whoever you, and maybe you
didn't get along with 'em,
but those kids would have to be different.
If you just love 'em the
way they are, it's well,
sometimes the way they are.
(Audience laughing) But
you know what I'm mean.
- No, wait, okay, so explain,
this is the third limited
series box set, right?
So explain why and why Bass Pro Shop.
I love Bass Pro Shop, but man, you go in
that place, it's like Target.
You go out with things you don't need,
but you love.
- Well you don't know you need them yet,
- Do you?
Okay, okay.
- You'll, you'll get there.
- Okay.
So not enough time,
but why, why, why this?
- Well, it is really cool.
So before you were born, we did the first
limited series, right?
(Audience laughing)
- No.
- So in the nineties
we did a limited series
and then in 2008 we did
a second limited series.
And now this is our last one.
And what it does is it allows you
to catch up on the past music
without having to pay for all of them.
So you kind of do hopefully a small price
for this, perfect for Christmas.
- Like a bundle
- Kind of stuff.
- Bundle's a beautiful word.
(audience laughing)
So it's, it's cool.
And Bass Pros, our partner,
you usually do it through big box retail.
And they're one of three
of the big boxes out there.
But the other two big box retailers,
just their music section
just keeps shrinking,
shrinking, shrinking down.
And this one we got to help
Johnny Morris and Ducks
Unlimited to work on
conservation of wildlife
with this box set.
- Oh wow.
- So it's a cool marriage.
So that's why we're here
together. (audience applauding)
- Beautiful.
Well I love that
Do you listen to your old stuff?
Are you always, you know....
- Oh my God, I love me.
- (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- I love, you're like, look
at this jam I did in 91.
- I can't believe I just said that.
Me and you, I'm getting way
too comfortable around here.
- No, you know why though?
It's actually very beautiful
because I, there are
sometimes I will say this,
it's only because of the performance.
There's some things I look back on.
I'm like, I did good on that one.
Like I get and I get proud
and I do listen to it.
I am a lot of my listens on....
It's because sometimes you do get really
proud of certain things you do.
And oh my god, when we were
kids in Oklahoma, Texas,
it was our dream to
get to accomplish this.
So it's like..
- Amen.
- You don't wanna take advantage of that
and just like really
recognize the blessing.
So I get that.
- Yeah, maybe guys are luckier than girls.
'cause girls are always harder
on themselves of course.
But guys keep it kind
of conversational, right?
(guitar strums)
So you can listen to the old stuff
and the old stuff isn't singing as much
as just tell me the story.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- So, so how was this residency?
Because I went to the last
one. This one was different.
Yeah, you did a different
thing. How has it been?
- So, you know Caesar's,
the stage is pretty wide
and it's pretty wide for a one man show,
no matter how much ground I cover,
it's, it's still wide kind of thing.
So what we did is we
put dinner tables out,
hung chandeliers
- Love
- And people are sitting
at those dinner tables,
but the people sitting at the
dinner tables are the band.
- Oh, I love that.
- So if you want to play
George Strait's Amarillo by Morning,
then Jimmy Mattingly just
picks up his fiddle, comes over
and plays with you and
goes back, sits down,
they're drinking all night.
At the end of the night
you'll see.
(Audience laughing)
But something, then the whole
band comes up and we play 'Friends.'
Or 'Callin' Baton Rouge,
some of that stuff.
So it's fun.
- Do you need to change it up like that?
- Yeah, because we got
through with the stadium run.
They say, how do you make it
bigger than the stadium run?
It's easy.
You guys know this.
Flip it on its head where
it's just me and you
and the music.
- Intimacy.
- That's when it gets big,
right? (audience applauding)
So cool.
And here's the cool thing
that people are kind
of a little bit odd about at first.
We bag the phones.
- Oh yeah, yeah yeah.
- So you bag the phones.
So you go in there.
So we've had people come in and,
and you get emails and letters and,
and little sweet notes that go.
We came in and we sat down
and some people sat down, we didn't know.
And you know what we did?
We started talking to them.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- It was like, are you kidding me?
- Who would've thought?
- Then they exchanged numbers,
they became best buddies.
They sang the same songs together
but didn't know each
other before that night.
To me, that's what music is.
Music is the voice of gathering.
- Connections.
- Right, 100%.
Music makes, I don't know,
music makes good of everything,
but I also think it's
the voice of hope for us
to end up being together as a whole unit.
I love Music.
- Me too.
I heard that you were playing new stuff.
- That's what you do.
- Like there was on this album,
you were playing that at the Vegas shows.
Which is so special for fans.
- So when you bag the phones, then you can
try new stuff on 'em, right?
And they don't know that they're coming in
thinking they're gonna have a good time.
Oh God.
It's amateur hour.
Here we go.
And you play them something
that they've never heard.
And I'm telling you, it's like a Polaroid.
It's instant.
You get, you get the instant you suck
or holy cow kind of thing,
Right?
(audience laughing) So
you get I'm into that.
Or like, oh, should I go to the bathroom?
- (laughing)
Alright, well tell me about this song.
It's St. Paul Minneapolis, right?
- Yeah.
- You did that one in Vegas, right?
- Yeah, and in parentheses
it says, 'A true story.'
- Oh, I love it.
So this really happened to me.
- I mean, tell me about the
story. So you ran into someone.
- Yeah.
And you can't tell much
because I really want this
person to tell me.
So this person knows everything.
But I gotta tell you
that it was something just really,
me and Miss Yearwood, we talk about it,
we take walks
and there was something so
easy about the conversation.
It was crazy.
So like, I just like to
find this person again
to see if, if it was something
that's always that way.
And if it is, I wanna know why it...
- Is it just something they
do. Or is it just (indistinct)
- I have no idea.
It, you know those
things you can't control.
- Yeah.
- Those feelings that come over you.
But I would love to see if I
could find this person and,
and just become friends.
She was, she was a great help
and a great period of time
and didn't ask for anything
or seem to assume anything in return.
- Oh my gosh.
- It's good.
- I Wanna find this person.
(audience applauding)
Ah, because I want the whole story.
(laughing)
Alright, well let's take a quick break
and grab some tissues.
The Garth Brooks plus
one residency returns
to the Coliseum at Caesar's
Palace starting November 29th.
Go online for ticket information.